[Musique]
oui on va
bah
m
hop
oh
[Musique]
des soutes à couettes malus est tu
regardes une athée c'est la fête pas tu
rappes sculpture rail littérature funk
couture 5/7 à arme politique papé
whack'n roll c'est la recette de
lunettes ginette noires pour nuits
blanches
le magazine du samedi soir bonsoir
l'artichaut bien au chaud chao pour tous
les petits lu et toutes les petites
lucielle encore un petit coup du mari de
bambou remettez nous ça prend pas
attention révélations franck clairement
pour l'une est le poète mur à antibes en
prêt chinois buffalo stance la fille de
john cher et neneh cherry
comme son nom l'indiqué graziella de
michel l'ex banque est des minguettes
musculaire blanc revient en blouson noir
et si tous les intellos était homo
interview with one dominique fernandez
les plus grands rockeurs sont ils des
losers alan vega l'interview vérité
bonjour les dégâts exclu their place
vers bakou macaigne ou mat le gang le
plus cool de la soul raul le coeur de
palace au palace pucéat tinéna suicider
vélo jean michel arrive très gospel
chopin aux animaux chansonnette puce
blindtest ray du net tout ça night
clubbing tout paris pour souffler les
bougies de marie bergère était là yes
indeed oliver reed l'auto interview la
plus voyou faveur du mousquetaire du
rail hyper distroll wacey lunettes
noires louis blanc
[Applaudissements]
kate ryan le stade you de light blue
bike and run run et nous croisons mid
une autre d'en maintenir la barre
specht lescaze des speakerines du
invendus aux fesses et de fort wayne
rooney man made in china
[Musique]
les lecteurs
amy d'artagnan tout cela est à moi vous
êtes un homme heureux pour tous dans mon
ami valeur
raul et moi sans en perdre et saône et
ses hommes
mais qu'est ce que vous croyez chemin de
fer
un pour tous pour halloween pour toutes
et tous
quinze ans après les trois mousquetaires
oliver reed interprète à tous dans vingt
ans après où le retour des mousquetaires
chapeau l'artiste
il ne soupçonne rien non combien de
garde à tf1 avec ordre de ne laisser
passer personne même sa majesté la reine
ban après midi monsieur justin
[Musique]
portant sur
à la diablesse
bon voyage messieurs
grand corps malade
boizel veut poser après deux spectacles
musicaux ce week end
[Musique]
on
2009 semble mamadou diop
[Musique]
robert godley niveau des contrôles
jacques tati team opt nous l'enlève de
fariboles
un gros beauf et violent
[Musique]
elle est tombée dedans maman quand elle
était petite sellerie pour la fille de
john chaire inédite chéri au sommet le
tour et shaft avec buffalo stunts s'est
créé 45 tours un joueur de l'année par
deux faits produit par tim simenon comme
son premier album raw like sushis parce
que le sushi c'est sexy qu'elle vit la
chérie
[Musique]
oui
notre pays
[Musique]
m
j
[Musique]
charest
nos salles qui
le maire
pays
non
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
une amie
je
il est
[Musique]
m
mais c'est nous
ouais
bellemare m omar el du mal
samedi
[Musique]
là
c'était nenê thierry de chéri chéri
chéri comme dire alice sapritch voici
graziella de michel aux questions code
ardison qui lui donne des ailes à la
michel alors graziella michel tu as dit
une fois que cette faisait chier de
faire le pingouin la télé c'est vrai
ouais pourquoi parce que ça me fait
chier c'est vrai que c'est contre ma
nature
c'est ton côté minguettes bande à baader
je sais pas c'est surtout mon côté j'ai
envie d'écrire des chansons de faire des
disques et des choses comme ça mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya tout un côté de ce
métier qui m'a pas l'effacer pas ça qui
m'a donné envie de faire des chansons
s'épanouir et à la télé tu as dis je
digère la fin du prolétariat jean noces
le statut d'artiste alors s'allier ça ça
rentre le métier ça commence t comment
s'est montré très fort là que quand même
c'était le pull-over blanc quatre cents
400 combien j'ai pas ils ont donné windy
reef à ils veulent pas de dire sinon je
ne sais pas je me suis jamais occupé
moment de ça c'est à peu près ça tu t'es
pris un peu de pognon quand même ouais
un épluche tanins plus mais c'est pour
ça que tu recommences alors ce qui est
très drôle c'est qu'à l'époque où ça a
commencé comme ça a marché le pull-over
blanc était infirmière dans un hôpital
psychiatrique et tu sortais de chez
sabatier que tu retournes à l'oustau le
soir ça c'est quoi ça ça faisait un
décalage
ce qui est intéressant c'est intéressant
quand même je vais pas faire trop la
rigolote là dessus parce que c'est vrai
que c'était intéressant est ce qui est
intéressant c'est le souvenir de tout ça
parce que ça me permet de me dire face à
mu ça me permet de me dire que y'a pas
que y'a pas que la chanson et je
n'oublie pas qu'un autre monde qui
existe
j'aimais beaucoup mes petits fours
prêtre a fait katy prend le train alors
là ce n'était pas franchement un succès
il faut bien que non parce qu'on a
travaillé trois mois sur ce titre
ouais je suis un des plus beaux titres
que j'ai fait ouais donc longtemps il
faut perdre un peu magnifiquement de
temps en temps vous gagnez un peu
beaucoup de gagner la savane ouais tu
fais un 33 tours
il s'appelle le clown d'avis quand je te
pose la question que tout le monde te
faut ça moi je connais la réponse mais
tu m'as donné c'est qui le clown
d'alicante que ça il faut apprendre à
tout à préparer pour les télés et qu'une
délit quand c'est un monsieur j'ai pas
beaucoup connu parce que c'est mon père
qui est parti quand j'avais 5 ans et qui
allait lui les drôles d'idées d'aller
mourir à alicante
et quand j'ai enfin une époque quand
j'ai su qu'il était là bas je me suis
dit qu'est-ce qu'il était allé faire le
clown alicante puis bon je sais c'était
quelqu'un dont j'avais fait un héros qui
était pas héros du tout en fait
j'en ai vu faire un espèce de
personnages sublime quoi t'es pas ça et
la chanson c'est ça c'est mon papa
mais pourquoi il avait été obligé
d'aller alicante je crois parce qu'il
était réfugié droit commun plus ou moins
politique non bref on sait pas trop
parce que comme c'était un ancien
mussolinien et là bas y avait plein de
franquiste à la retraite je crois je
pense qu'après la guerre il serait parti
en espagne chez franck et les donneurs
il a fait le mercenaire et après s'est
réfugié chez dans l'espagne un peu
à droite c'est pas mal comme destin
c'est assez romanesque entre les
castrais omanaise jaurès puis je me
demande où est la part de roulement qui
est la part de réalité
mais je préfère me va rester comme ça
faire savoir tout ça comme ça voilà pas
trop ça mais veulent connaître tout
c'est pas des questions compte mais on y
est ou question qu'on regarde que tu
viens tu fais mon travail
[Musique]
question qu'on sait très bas mais l'apd
est un regard par exemple jusqu'au objet
de faire l'amour
est-ce que tu prête maintenant la well
as là tout de suite dans les caméras est
ce que tu possèdes il en faudrait peu
parce que bourré comme je suis avec les
paupières d'amour avec une jolie fille
ou avec un mec très laid avec un break
très laid quand même ah bon là
maintenant qu'ils me demandent ouais
t'es qu'un mec très laid peut-être parce
que tu as essayé que c'est à peu près
faire signer vos parents ils vont
retirer la garde de l'enfant
justement alors faire une question qui
va faire plaisir à tes beaux parents un
ton mec donc ça peut arriver leur fils
c'est un soir comme celle ait pas bon je
vais arriver la science-fiction toujours
oui j'espère pour toi en tous les cas
alors qu'est-ce que tu choisis tu
discutes avec lui tu lui dis c'est cette
fille tu la connais tu m'aimes plus
qu'est ce que je t'ai fait bon première
solution serait une solution tu fais un
truc très spécial tu connais tu sais que
ça lui plaît les troisièmes bon tu te
casses en claquant la porte en disant
connard je préfère la toute première
solution parce que c'est alexis très
complètement pas que tu lui parles de la
fille même si c'est pas vrai c'est alors
oui tu discutes os un jeu alors
maintenant on va faire les moeurs vrai
comment tu préférais mourir mais en fait
il que tu vas en angleterre un stade tu
préférais mourir que tué par un skinhead
tué dans un accident d'avion ou tués
dans un stade tout ça est typiquement
anglais
l'accident d'avion parce que du coup je
rentrerai dans la légende du rock genre
comme de diorite oussalé mort john avait
jusque là on les critique rock du coup
dans rain man justement si tu devais
mourir comme une star du rock tu
préférais mourir comme otis redding ou
buddy holly en avion comme john lennon
avec un coup de revolver dans le ventre
comme ça à bout portant et à péchiney
rebond ces jeunes tout peut arriver
comme janis joplin d'une overdose
non et comme le mec da si d'ici là bonne
scott tu sais qui est mort dans son vomi
alors comme otis redding comme otis
redding toujours l'avion j'ai tellement
peur en avion que me dit un jour ça que
je lui prends pas si je le prendrais
vont chaque fois c'est genre ah bon
testament avant et que tu fais tu bois
n'ont rien je suffit pas mais alors
imagine que le petit adrien coutume
heures dont tu es morte
ah ouais d'accord maintenant laisser le
jeu tu es morte le petit adrien il est
confiée à la mère n'ont pas la taille
justement est-ce que tu préférais qu'il
soit confié à france gall gib à dakar ça
sera un tube avec ah oui bon il soit
confiée à françoise hardy non atteints
rasidi un front voix sylvie vartan ou
chez lexus et fait des classiques
non j'en attends sheila sylvie vartan
secours passe quand même enfin secours
qu'elle fait
faut dire que cinq ans observé jaime
bien ouais c'est entre sheila et
françoise hardy quoi ah ouais cheney un
côté comme ça rassurant et tout vent
puis en ce moment là pas trop de boulot
elle pourrait sonner
bon allez on prend chez la question
traditionnelle sont pas si cons conseil
risques ne sont pas tendus tout est
question le vaisseau spatial femmes sont
moins conquérir le vaisseau spatial
ouais tu es prête
ouais bon avec qui tu préférais partir
fais gaffe parce que là tout vers jean
te regarde réfléchit bien tu pars avec
mon max guazini de nrj as tu veux te
fâcher avec un accès sûr avec patrice
blanc francard d'europe numéro un oui
avec monique lemarcis d'rtl et sites web
catherine lara parce qu'elle est là
toutes les saint louis les 84
elle aura tant fait gaffe ce cas là je
dirais max passe comme il est beau
garçon
ouais c'est bien très bien ils vont
faire ça il est formidable pour une
phrase pas grand et beau garçon
oui et quatre ans en me faisant peur
quand même un rêve de quatre ans avec
max guazini maxi qui est vraiment il est
surprenant vos garçons j'apprendrai
choix des duos avec legendary donne à
ronan qui me dit max parce que monique
le marcy
mboulou première radio de france
bah oui mais moi j'aime les garçons
bon alors entravé damas et deux enfants
tueurs congrès n'en commet pas confiné
m
fini les excès de los angeles
la vraie vie made in virginie mommayou
maquis se sont débarrassés des bentley
ils ont fait don des sacs vuitton vivant
pour deux chansons
voici celebrate the world extrait de la
30 points conscience juste avant les
vacances
ce type en exclu
tout temps
tu peux
jenine eux
le méchant
[Musique]
connect plus normal
et
tu
oh
[Musique]
tous
mais ce club
sa venue
mais non
oui
à
[Musique]
suite
cette année
je ne sais pas
m
[Musique]
ah oui
je fais
[Musique]
deuxième single extrait du 33 tours
comme chaîne c'était au makhzen ou mac
celebrate the world
ouais si jean michel ribes aux parades
pour bad ass neuf épisodes à partir du
28 avril où ça sur a2 à ne pas manquer
un peu comme la vingtaine de lunettes
vous voyez pour jean michel ribes
bonsoir quand tu as dit que tu savais
pas parler des choses que tu avais
écrite est là donc on a fait le maximum
que je compte amis au palace pour parler
de place donc en fait à faire plus et ça
commence le 28 avril sur antenne 2 ces
neuf épisodes de vendredi soir
en face de sabatier tu le sais ça oui
mais moi ça ne c'est pas pour ça que
j'étais pas là c'est pas finir en face
de sabatier où même lui faire la guerre
je vais moi je fais pas là c'est parce
que ça m'amuse et c'était quelque chose
dont j'avais envie j'ai pas vraiment
fait pas la semaine des as lors
l'histoire c'est quoi ce se passe dans
un palace et ses dégâts que d'en faire
c'est pâques dégâts tant faire c
une idée de à la base de cession fait
chair qui un jour m'a téléphoné et m'a
dit voilà j'ai envie vers grande
émission d'humour dans un lieu rêvé un
palace vous en pensez vous puisque vous
pouvez le faire vous avez carte blanche
ans et une baisse de rêve quand on a
commencé à téléphoner à des gens que
j'aime bien comme doctor comme bouriaud
gp valence qui interviennent ils aiment
absolument et puis un jour on a dit à
fait cher bon bah qu'est ce qui se passe
parce qu'on va pas aller tourner au ritz
au crayon qu'est ce qui se passe là on
va le construire
chose qu'on n'imaginait pas grand
producteur et on est en a on a osé
hostiou de boulogne dont il est
propriétaire maintenant changer les
choses qui arrange les choses il a fait
construire un palace d'auray vous
pouvoir pour moi est que patrick
dutertre à à dessiner et voilà
[Musique]
messieurs pourrait voir votre dimaté 65%
t'as vu sa dann quel score pour un sport
spa score ça fait combien de
téléspectateurs ses environs ont ça ça
fait trente millions de téléspectateurs
et 30 millions c'est exceptionnel nous
plaisons beaucoup c'est vrai nous c'est
qu'ils nous la directeur des clients
personnels ont pas payé le concierge
aussi je suis concierge car les gens ce
moment qu'est ce qu'ils regardent un le
concert annoncé lui qu'il y ait les deux
tiers de la france planté devant la télé
regardait le concierge d'un palace est
tous à nous d'autres ça arrive aux
restes tu nous prends pour un con quoi
t'as vu ta tronche tu ferais zappé un
macaque jeu juste sur alors tu nous
expliques expliquer quoi est ce ma faute
si je plais si les jours même si je
séduis bon aller où elles sont là et
filles à poil
y'a pas un audimat qu'il est passé
trente pour cent des filles à poil et là
vous êtes déjà 62%
tout allait mal vous avez dépassé le
quota autorisé ça va vous coûter cher
monsieur on a été contrôlé chi x on n'a
jamais trop d sur la fille ou alors tu
veux pas nous dire oh tu les plantes
nous sommes pas là si monsieur pas
importer ici il n'ya pas de femmes
dénudées pour attirer la clientèle
c'est comme il voudra aller faire un
petit tour
allez c'est parti et tu as corrigé des
choses par rapport à ce que les les
privilégiés
de canal+ ont pu voir oui c'est à dire
que bon c'est vrai que canal+ est aussi
à l'origine de ce projet puisque son
coproducteur avec christian et disons
que j'ai l'impression que sur canal + on
a eu comme les bars marx brothers avant
de jouer à new york y faisait des
tournées dans lé vivoter de show rodé
pour voir un marché alors canal+ a été
un peu ce banc d'essai maintenant j'ai
l'impression qu'on a vraiment figer le
le produit l'émission dans la forme la
plus qu'ils n'ont rien tapé les neuf
qu'on va voir son geste mais revoit
espère si jamais les gens nous regardent
on va te regarder ces gentils on va te
regarde et on va faire une interview à
peine dames savent que c'est le plus le
moins tu es prêt oui
[Musique]
le plus comique à part toi ce n'est qu'
arrêter les jours je pense que ça doit
être d'aider josé ce que joseph poli qui
était droite bruno masure joseph poli je
trouve que c'est je crois la vie est
plus belle que je trouve que c'est plus
comique quand même que ce qui se passe
non mais je veux dire qu'il ya une
division qui est basé sur des gens du
rire il semblait basé sur les
chansonniers gouvernement remet
heureusement chirac fois l'aubrac
c'est sur l'actualité qu'on bouffe tout
tout tout de suite mais je sais pas s'il
ya vraiment des auteurs je ne pense pas
qu'il appela place aujourd'hui pour
alphonse allais pour un des grands
d'humoristes quoi et j'ai l'impression
que on s'est resserré dans palace et que
là il ya vraiment des auteurs est
vraiment des acteurs cirque on joue
comme on joue au cinéma comme on joue
été appris mon jour par voie d'appels à
vie par le théâtre j'ai appris que tu as
fait ton premier spectacle à 19 ans ce
même problème c'est que les pièces que
quand on a découvert c'est à dire les
fraises musclé le sycobs avec l âge
j'avais oui j'ai commencé à écrire toi
18 ans et puis est arrivé à être avant
garde sans être zappé les autres eric
faure de rita pas le sentiment comme ça
te faire un peu bouffé par la télé de
dans la g dire la vérité c'est que vu
les difficultés qu'on a eu pour remettre
enfin certaines séquences dans ce qui
est appelé devant ce qui est appelé le
grand public
vraiment vraiment qu'on est restés
cohérents enfin je suis resté cohérent
et moi je n'arrive pas à faire autre
chose que ce que j'aime et ce que je
vois ce sens et c'est une infirmité je
n'arrête pas de me dire mais pourquoi
vous faites pas des choses pour le grand
public mais j'ai l'impression de faire
des choses normales à ses très grand
public
oui laquelle tu préfères le tout petit
il ya une pièce deux pièces dans une
pièce nous pour reprendre la
classification d'âne ou une pièce noire
une pièce rouge j'ai beaucoup aimé tous
contre un petit bac mais créac'h michel
marques et roland blanc stéphane oui
celle que tu aimes le moins pas celles
que j'aime le moins reluisant comme ça
c'est celle que j'avais créé au théâtre
de la ville qui s'appelait le lycée pour
une tasse de thé donc été un grand
bateau comme ça mais où je n'y étais pas
investi totalement qui avaient
formidablement marché des daaf et deux
films ont finalement levé rien ne va
plus et villeray et puis après il ya eu
la galette dur ou alors qu'est ce que tu
préfères dans le cinéma
je préfère pas mes deux films qui sont
pas pour moi des choses j'ai pu
m'exprimer complètement ya là quelque
chose qui est très très intéressant
soucier le rapport du producteur dire
que si on n'est pas 2,6 on est on n'est
pas ensemble dans le même désir ça
marche pas ça marche est pas là c'est
parce qu'avec téchené on était ensemble
en vue d'aider en parlant des
producteurs au cinéma on travaille avec
des gens avec qui on dirait pas
ouais c'est vrai effet voilà peut-être
te faire faire des films oui on a des
projets ouais c'est quoi qui te fait le
plus rire quand même j'espère c'est ce
qui fait plus rire la distille des
situations décalées cpr que j'adore
quand tout d'un coup des gens continuent
à être normaux et a parlé de choses tout
à fait quotidienne et puis que le tel
que n'est plus les plusieurs qui essaie
ça c'est ce que j'aime c'est ce qu'il ya
peu dans palace c'est à dire des choses
un peu qui dérape était drôle quoi dans
la vie parce que les gens qui écrivent
du comique souvent sont pas en moi je
suis pas spécialement drôle je peux être
drôle comme ça quand j'ai du public
mais sinon ce nom c'est plutôt quelqu un
de ses envois c'est pour moi c'est
chiant avis qu'est-ce que tu es le plus
cher justement parce qu'il fait plus
chier dans la vie c'est vraiment je
crois que c'est vraiment le chose qui
serait entre la vie mérite et la bêtise
quoi ca c'est quelque chose dont on est
tous complètement quand les gens
quand les gens sont vulgaires y ait une
très jolie il ya une très jolie
définition de la vulgarité par baltasar
gracian soit quelqu'un jésuite espagnol
farres aider qu'est ce que c'est que la
ville a été aiguisée
c'est le manque d'intelligence est sûr
que nous regardes tu réfléchis c'est
tout à fait juste
mais tu as écrit beaucoup de choses sur
le suicide quand même ça y est presque
la moitié de rennes le temps 9 sur le
suicide
oui j'étais j'ai été très touché par les
gens qui se suicident et je trouve qu'il
y avait un regain d'un coup quelqu'un
qui s'est suicidé on lit son nom ce
qu'il a écrit tout à fait différemment
c'est comme un label de sincérité de
qualité et c'est vrai qu'il ya des
personnages j'étais le premier jeu qu'on
avait rassemblé maintenant il sait où il
va chez cravans errigo à inventer
l'humour sans âge c'est vrai on s'en va
c'est exactement je connais tu
travailles beaucoup comme ça pour pas
suicidé peut-être peut-être si ce n'est
pas une mauvaise définition c'est en
tout cas c'est pour survivre je sais que
moi je travaille pas je tombe presque on
a une espèce de vélo et s'apprête à
tomber
c'est vrai que c'est une c'est une
survie quoi clairement on va essayer
jean louis murat deschamps en ville pour
un anti portrait chinois débrider un
jean louis murat bonsoir bonsoir
tu as commencé par des petits boulots
tettey coiffe plagistes
bomberman barma remet le disque
ouais quand été à saint-tropez fait que
tu voyais avec du showbiz il faisait
quoi leur sert de l1 ça m'excite un peu
et ça me débecte hervouet de servir
barclays quand on est un
maintenant enfin non pas que tu es là
enfin maintenant que tu fais des disques
tu les trouves toujours aussi salopards
utilisait bien sûr encore plus ou moins
ce sera encore plus si cette vente est
monté à paris une première fois ce qui
est très drôle d'ailleurs ton histoire
cia clermont ferrand du monde apparaît
une 3d sans avec l'arbre remonte à paris
à la première fois que tu es monté
c'était là où tu as rencontré légendaire
annoncé qu'ils ont un peu aidé quand
même bassil pharand toute la bande
ouais et puis après tu as fait un groupe
est redescendu d'abord du tennis est un
peu compliqué pour moi donc tu
redescendu d'épitaphe un groupe qui
s'appelait clara et puis un jour tu as
vu débarquer vers william sheller jean
bernard eibel c'était pas mal c'était
sympa un grosse surprise pour moi
ouais c'est encourager les gens bernard
qui était le fan de la première heure
qui m'a suivi péta des fans comme ça
ouais on a essayé il ya des gens qui
sont des fanatiques de vivre à la plus
en plus qui devraient être assurés et
qu'elle sera prête en a fait une chanson
qui s'appelait suicidez vous le peuple
est mort c'est 56 tard ça c'est un
scandale national
ben oui parce que
enfin sa porte pas sourire évidemment
mais enfin c'est à dire qu'il ya c'est
l'époque du suicide mode d'emploi lé
signe chez morrow 1 et quelques indices
y est maintenant suicider c'est ça qui
ce qui se serait suicidé pour autre
chose que ce qu'on se suicide peu pour
une chanson mais enfin c'est a servi de
prétexte et pour moi ça a été une
rupture un tour
mot dire ils ont arrêté de te passer à
la radio a tout fait tandis que pathé a
tout arrêté
c'était moche et à la morale ouais alors
hop qui pousse au cul avec le suicide il
a été obligé d'arrêter les groupes hbos
ouais ça va chauffer pour ta des prix
mais là tu as dit des trucs terribles
attentats des primes quoi tu dis si tu
t'étais enlever tous les poils tu disais
c'est quoi cette histoire s'est pas je
m'étais enlever tous les poils c'est
pourquoi j'étais malheureux c'était
malheureux je voulais sauter par la
fenêtre du tpi cette surdité
c'était g 1
tu te défoncer c'était suite à des
histoires de défense
c'est un mélange de déception amoureuse
surtout c'était surtout ma propre
déception
je savais que j'allais y arriver mais ça
arrive et pas moi ça c'est terrible
relaté nouveau a clairement fait hors tu
viens à paris pour la promo à l'hôtel
ouais étudie comment est clair moi je
suis un pendant un pépère ouais ouais
spartiate
ouais un peu de bonheur ouais je
travaille il fait du sport je fais des
chansons d'abord sait comment mettre là
bas
ça me fait ni chaud ni froid en fait
j'ai mis deux clairement jeu pour
habiter ailleurs
ouais tout doucement j'habite chez moi
je sais pas si ça veut rien dire c'est
un peu tout dire
clermont ferrand signifie qu aucun
charme ce charme que je trouve que c'est
chez moi
mais tu te défonces part et où tu crois
il avait gagné un moment c'est pourquoi
j'en prends un truc ah bon et pourquoi
c'est pas c'est devenu mon ami il ya un
quart d'heure gens cherchent un peu ça
se trouve c'est non ouais mais j'avais
pour mes dents mancelle
ce pôle plus dur à trouver ça ça te fait
quoi je dis bien ouais hein et des
effets secondaires cody coded un peu en
latin signé avec leurs jeans pour six
albums tu es tranquille là pendant trois
ans maintenant vos potes enfants chez
fameux sera quitte pour six ans ouais et
encore qui sait ils peuvent te virer
dessus mais toi tu peux pas partir non
j'en ai pas envie d'un apport vivre sans
gentil avec toi c'était l'impression
d'un an que ça y est on a trouvé un
autre chez toi d'une famille une famille
apparaît tu as des projets à part d'être
retourné paysans parce que tes grands
parents étaient paysans
j'ai été élevé l'emmène en temps tu as
envie de faire ça pour ton est encore
plus loin que la monf héros quoi j'ai
presque envie de redevenir mon grand
père
le futur m'intéresse pas vous
c'est bizarre comme
ou ciciba écoute on va te faire le
gentil portrait chine ça c'est terrible
pour des clients comme toi c'est ce qu'à
mieux
si tu étais un défaut tu serais quoi
j'étais un défaut ouais l'envi qu'il est
en vie mais lasses où vit un peu ton
envie là ça va non pas encore je vais
très très star
une injure ça je sais pas un cap a bien
sûr été incapable d'injures si mon amant
en agence et celle de nietzsche qui sait
donner à l'autre la honte de soi c'est
la pire chose qu'il fait des fois quand
tu servait à saint-tropez dans les
rampes de toile ces sacs pour ça que tu
leur emploi et barclays et nettoyer ses
chemises tachées à la mousse au chocolat
ses terres et puis je comprends ce après
une fille les dix axes et un vampire
c'était une infirmité
j'étais une infirmité autres incapable
les médiations un assassin tige est un
assassin peut-être landru parce qu'il
aimait vraiment les femmes et une guerre
guerre la guerre 17 la guerre des sexes
je passe bien quand même
c'est toujours avec cette fille qui
s'appelle marie quitte équilibre tu vas
rester longtemps du toit petit à petit
tu as trouvé ton chez toi tu as trouvé
ton perdu tu as trouvé mari ça va
s'arranger si tu étais une arme à double
tranchant
giuly c'est rudi stiller madame sting au
palace je n'ai rebelles et revoici jenny
bel'air roi de la nuit pas laurent
voulzy banane val-andré charlotte qui en
ce moment dit piotte et scénarios pour
de futurs bravo c'est sur l'a6 qu'il
sévisse nagui qui croient que l'amant
d'osier t2 un bisou très mal cool
inconnu de la semaine françois dimanche
c'est vraiment dément
[Musique]
je jette et non jeu
reste aux morts
quand ces veilles l'ange dans mon bar
voix
oh
j'arrache des pierres
aux murs épais
et
du tombeau de terre
dumas jeter et je m'en attendais
tous
par les chemins
tu
le poignet
les assassins
[Musique]
ni berges de sambre pour aimer n'existe
pas
tu
parfois je pris mon
on ne m'oublie pas chat
toujours la nostalgie nous
sans vous tous
non des vignerons
[Musique]
le sou
g
du temps sûrement
tu
j'ai connu sa douche
tu es
m
nami ne mange
[Musique]
mon corps un talus
dieu à m
lange
l'enjeu des gîtes
mais
tu as
c'est et l'ange déchu et on n'est pas
déçu jean louis murat
voici dominique fernandez quand les
autres sortent du gui taureaux sont ils
encore géniaux interview ce boulot par
dominique fernandez après porporino
l'étoile rose dans la main de l'ange la
gloire du paria tu publies chez grasset
le rap de ganymède alors il faut
expliquer ce que c'est parce que c'était
ganymède oui oui ce qu'elle rate aussi
la nuit mais c'était le plus beau le
plus beau jeune homme en grèce
oui si beau que jupiter le roi des dieux
on est tombé éperdument amoureux et
s'est déguisé en aigle pour l'emporter
au ciel d oui oui il en a fait son temps
avant 10 ans allemand ce qui prouve que
définitivement l'homosexualité est un
signe d élection divine donc absolument
alors la société et homophobes ça c'est
sûr je veux dire toute façon elle est de
moins en moins on va y venir et tu dis
que les lucides dans les grands
témoignages de la culture nos sexuelle
et tu dis que finalement tout ce qui
s'est produit bien par des homosexuels
remonte à l'époque de la de la honte et
de la clandestinité elle qui me chagrine
c'est parce que le thème du livre c'est
la création à vis des contraintes et
meurent des libertés le souci c'est ça
me chagrine beaucoup parce qu'en même
temps comme en tant que citoyen je suis
ravi du progrès j'ai merdé par les ouïes
auquel j'ai contribué un petit peu à la
bonne mesure mais en tant que créateur
en tant que lecteur de livres je
constate que depuis qu'on est libre sur
depuis vingt ans mais ton médicament
leem d'homosexuels et sont même très
très mauvais il ya de plus en plus parce
qu'apparemment louis pas d'édition
homosexuels comme vous mettre un peu les
pistes
monsieur du commercial est plus tout ça
n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'ils avaient
avant mais en tant que co caractère de
littérature de
deux films aussi une sem chose tant tout
est filmé une scène dès maintenant sinon
mais qui souvent ont senti de commerce
pour faire un petit clin d'oeil c'est
pas c'est pas vécu vraiment solide du
coup tu la vie comment cette
contradiction parce que donc tu es
responsable de quelque chose que tu
regardes quand même mes prochains
projets romands y aura pas du tout
d'homosexualité alors deuxième chose
c'est le sida quand même parce que c'est
vrai que l'ultime éléments tragique
c'est par le sida c'est la
réintroduction de la tragédie dans la
sexualité est complètement libérée 68
ce qui n'était jamais produit dans
l'histoire d'humanité avant ouais
c'était fort hills est allé si vite et
rosé ce qu'on voulait revivre les temps
rien tant mieux huit ans qui est cette
chose affreuse de tomber et qui rentre
d'une tragique et le risque du ragondin
la gloire des parias dans la composition
yahia 2 de héros il y en a pour qui
c'est grave et un pour qui c'est naturel
le prêt jeune pour lui c'est pas un
problème à la haye l'ancien il retrouve
sa jeunesse et à la culpabilité à la
marge londres l'horreur dans son bouquin
tu fais un espèce d'inventaire comme ça
dès les oeuvres qui ont été données par
la clandestinité la honte
j'essaie de ne pas faire du racolage
c'était magnifique parce que j'aurais pu
faire un livre de dix mille pages et
nous on voudrait presque tous les grands
créateurs lhenry venir justement parce
que c'est vrai qu'il a un peu tendance
fin je m'en voudra pas mais c'est vrai
qu'on a un peu tendance
il en était il en était quand même c'est
à dire que les homosexuels ont toujours
tendance à penser que la plupart des
gens en sont
l'asim si ça sonne un petit matin ça ce
sont les plus sûrs les ça c'est évident
ça oui ça c'est évident seul van
beethoven ans à moi je savais pas mais
ces vérités pas il ya les homosexuels
qui vit qui avait une vie homosexuelle
comme léonard de vinci et vivendi ce qui
se reflète même bien sûr mais n'ont
jamais su qu'il était mais la vie des
taux mais c'est là où c'est déjà plus
suspect est un rationnement et son neveu
car l hôtel il torturait ce neveu dont
il avait la charge était vraiment
amoureux lui et jalousie féroce en
empêcher de sortir de vivre tout ça pour
pas que je nomme 7-6 a voulu se suicider
le natif de celui-ci tellement il était
sous l'emprise de cette tombe formidable
qui est terrifiant absolument mozart
mozart je sais pas mais il ya un an il a
écrit ça c'est comme un scoop au cycle
libre à l'âge de 11 ans mais comme
j'étais déjà génial puis à 24 ans et il
a écrit un opéra dont le sujet tout à
fait homosexuels c'est bel apollon
hyacinthe et apollon était un autre dieu
qui était amoureux d'un jeune homme il
ya cinq arrêtés european opéra
homosexuel je ne dis pas plus de morts
que j'étais là et un opéra à ce sujet
positionner sa personne ne sait pas ce
que c'est le radeau de la méduse
d'ailleurs en contrôler la fin de leurs
études ou qui jerry owei allait bien
alors quand on le regarde quand on voit
le monde
il ya une scène homosexuelle et même est
encore mieux c'est dans la marseillaise
2 rue de l'arc de triomphe
sparrow liège où la liste de mégère qui
entraîne les soldats à la guerre des
millions de do de touristes le regarde
sans voir qu'il ya un jeu de vue aux
failles a nommé
ce qui entraîne un jeune homme tout nu
sous prétexte d'aller à la guerre mais
s'exiter rapports homosexuels évident je
dis et si vous regardez là où c'est un
peu plus piqué des hannetons c'est
schubert pour la main à joubert je dis
pas ouais je me demande pourquoi est
elle toujours à l'espace complexe
d'échec quoi ils finissaient pas c est
pourquoi est ce qu'il ne réussisse pas à
vivre j'ai réalisé un rapport à ses amis
qui sont attestés je crois que lui n'a
rien fait il n'y a pas de certains
textes dont je pense pas qu'ils pensent
pas mais si il aurait bien sûr les
femmes ont toujours été malheureuse où
il était amoureux de contest qui dit
socialement aussi absolument hors
d'atteinte pour lui est quelqu'un qui a
des échecs répétés avec les femmes il ya
quand même raison je veux dire à louis
devancé verlaine permet à bohars ça
encore une chose qu'on occulte dans les
lycées on vous raconte vers les amours
qui on vous dit que vermelles tiré un
coup de pistolet sur un bond à bruxelles
où on dit jamais pourquoi ce qui nous
fait de scènes de jalousie et la crime
comme il y en a tout autant concernés
nationale qatarie passionnel et alors il
des poèmes érotiques verlaine com publie
pas si non seulement tous qu'ils sont
très très très beau c'est ce qui a deux
c'est mieux
là aussi on les cache alors proust oscar
wilde on parle même pas roger martin du
gard des noms alors ça par contre
j'étais sur vos box est l'auteur lalie
tivo et tout abus et les cinq tomes et
ce qu'elle chine et si tu te bats est le
mot mort qui parle posthume durée de
cinq ans après sa mort ils sont du
colonel de mort c'est l'histoire de
colonne et qui raconte qu'il était
homosexuel depuis depuis sa jeunesse
dans sa demande culpabilité parce que
les générations à dire qu'on extrêmement
coincé alors j concept dans les
corridors il donc bon bouquin
tu l'avais déjà dit ça à lucile exemple
c'est aussi de refouler lui je pense
qu'il a très peu fait chose avec le show
mais profite merlus a profité
formellement sa création car ces films
sur les analyses de ce point de vue pour
respecter jeune homme qui met à mort des
dégâts des scènes d'un érotisme les
refoulés à retourner voir les films ben
t'as mise en scène on est tous restés au
land aulas aurait de marche mais de les
canons de potemkine la nasa cdu csu et
alité ville disent confiants c'est pas
joli des français mishima ben on sait
aussi enfin des gens qui savent un peu
mort il s'est enfoncé montherlant
montherlant bruisser cachemire est comme
un arracheur de dents est ce que ça que
j'ai passé qu'ils veulent ça ce sens
l'écriture du mensonge tempe ou laisser
rhétorique on sent que l'important est
de foot d'escamoter ans fernandez donc
est ce que toi tu penses que si tu
n'avais pas été homosexuel se récrie des
moins bons mais finalement je crois que
j'aurais une shot pas écrit du tout
jantes être une autre chose manière gens
d'ailleurs écrivait quand même ton père
ramon fernandez il avait brigué minnawi
ouais non la guerre
il n'y a pas que les homosexuels oui
avant la guerre qui écrivait dire
quelque chose de mal et après cris alors
ça va être quelque à qui on peut aimer
temps d'une femme qui dit plaqué ce qui
est une source de création au sam
la question c'est est ce qu'on peut
faire la littérature avec les bons
sentiments non ils sont tous peut pas
faire de la littérature avec le bonheur
à la barre tu vois ça comme ans pour
finir l'avenir de la culture
homosexuelle parce que quand on voit ça
maintenant tu nous dis que c'est fini
c'est grave quand même pas ce moment il
ya ya ya ya ya
mais pourquoi il ya si peu de bons
romans en france on est là parce qu'à
passer d'un mode c'est que mal non parce
qu'on peut plus clair parce que le
verdict des grands romans étaient des
homosexuels quand même
la plupart en france depuis depuis 100
ans notre très peu qui soient vraiment
purement hétéro alors une tête de cris
une frappe tendue qui est l'un des
mutations l'a peut-être en réfléchissant
3 d'autres moyens d'expression l'au delà
de la firme est vraiment intéressant et
point man je crois que fait autre chose
moi je toucherai plus à jouer ses rêves
ses deux fils âgés prépare quoi un gros
roman vieira sera tout à fait autre
chose
un homme une femme un homme deux femmes
et un homme toujours quand même heure
c'est l'année les animaux après l'ours
gérabilité les dauphins du grand bleu
voici aux animaux farid chopel acteurs
fument un réalisateur et quand il chante
celle où est ton avis
[Musique]
conférence est 1
la jument douala panthère quels
éléphants coléoptères
[Musique]
le but
photo t
[Musique]
oui
gwe
[Musique]
o o
à
tél
[Musique]
et maintenant
c'est quoi
[Musique]
tout ça
et jésus
oui
[Musique]
non
à gaillac
la malade est logique
[Musique]
4 millions
c'est une équipe en 4 4
tarak ben rushlo matin et wav lyon
[Musique]
c'était farid voici chapelle qui vient
de terminer le banquet de platon avec
série
farid perrier zen stone blind test c'est
fou non enfin il s'appelle bonsoir
bonsoir thiery coach a dit que je
ressemblais à robert de niro
oui on m'a déjà dit ça et je trouve
qu'il a une énorme chance tu passes ton
temps dans les boîtes les caractères
tout casser o'barry quinze jours je
passe tout mon temps dans les bois tu
passes le monde pendant les boîtes
quand je m'ennuie je dois dire la vérité
wajih place et j'ai cassé dire que j'ai
eu
j'ai envoyé valser quatre tables avec
tout ce qui avait déçu ouais c'est parce
que j'avais une journée un peu énervé
ces attaques mais de la veille 1
cette annonce ne m'a rien coûté s'il
veut financièrement parlant et tout même
c'est comme à dos m'ont fait cadeau oui
c'est comme ça c'est passé simplement
j'étais énervé j'ai cassé et table et
tout sur rock n roll quoi d'ailleurs
non c'est bon pour la légende t contre
le cocooning quoi toute façon les gens
qui restent chez eux en regardant la
télé sous la couette et toi non je suis
pas contre mais je dis aux rêves est
sisi ses dépens qu'il ya sous la couette
avec sa tenue en laisse et s'éclairer
nadon farid on n'est pas là pour rigoler
nous sommes d'accord on est là pour
faire la promo de tandis qu on fait la
promo de sa s'attelle aux animaux aux
animaux aux accents accent circonflexe
animaux royal mais pourrais tu fais
tu vas des spectacles comme tu faisais
là non mais choisira t il
attendez je te rends tu te fasses
malheureux mehdi non pour être un
centimètre autour de la tête parce que
tu as peur de la wii vendues justement
mater de fait 56 cm ouais tu vois et
sur-mesure tous les jours et je veux pas
tu as grossistes
ouais bref je te disais plus loin téoula
aux paroles de la chanson on n'en a pas
du tout on en était donc après le film
est tout et caetera et tu disais que je
te disais moi j'étais en train de te
dire si tu veux qu'elle absolument à
moins de spectacle je faisais beaucoup
et que nous spectateurs nous l'aurait le
temps que je te raconte le voyage à 10,1
fois que j'ai fait un spectacle s'était
pris de la girafe
ouais c'était donc il ya deux ans et
entre temps il m'arrive est une aventure
mais extraordinaire est tombé du 4e je
suis tombé du 4e étage
tu m'en souviens c'était un premier de
l'an c'était le premier de l'an 88
j'ai voulu aller souhaiter bonne année à
un pote à des amis au lieu de passer par
l'escalier j'ai dit tiens je vais
frapper par la façade
parce que tu sois moi je suis un peu
aller orléans
honda a donc c'est pas de l'amour euh
ouais et alors et donc je grimpe à la
façade fermement j'ai loupé une prise et
j'ai fait une chute extraordinaire et j
rebondi comme un chat ce qui fait que
bon ça quand même
ça m'a quand même de mobiliser quelques
mois et le temps de réfléchir et de me
dire que de prendre le temps de faire un
disque et mais là je prépare un
spectacle et la simple et comment la
belle carlo oui la belle carlo comme tu
dirais la belle otero way et disent que
ça veut dire carlo n'a carlo en argot ça
veut dire car abad donc la belle carlo
la belle caravane
tu vas nous expliquer à l asie pour
l'instant ça sera une tragi comédie
musicale
ouais parce que je trouve que le terme
est jolie et que pour l'instant la gemme
employés que c'est parce que c'est moi
une tragi comédie musicale moi non quand
je n'aurai pas une trajectoire oui ça
c'est dire que ce sera avec un orchestre
des chansons et des bêtises des bêtises
et les chansons tu veux que je vois un
homme triste
ouais
[Musique]
arrêtes tu me files pour s e faghih donc
jours encore on va passer au blind test
accepté
oui moi je dirais la star du raï à la
trèche n'ont pas encore une chance tiens
là la femme chat ou quatre sous oui
et parce que parce que tu appelles
l'egypte siat temps en temps tu appelles
égyptien s'attend même pas absolument
pas parce que je sais que c'est vrai
quelque part que nous est pas juste
quand même le descendant d'aménophis cat
diana ton et cetera des gardiens du
phare titi quand on dit que tu es beurre
ça t'emmerde quand même conduit si le
terme et tout bagage une vache est
toujours dit que j'étais parisien je
dire on est par ici on s'en fout mais
pourquoi parce que ta famille est
arrivée en france y'a longtemps c'est
pour ça que ma survie est arrivé en sont
intégrés mais moi je moi je suis pas
intégré je suis 10 intérêts
non agir la famille c'est arrivé en 1937
endroit magique viard et la clé
plusieurs relations déjà eu dans ma
famille ils n'ont jamais parlé
on est d'origine kabyle voilà ma tête je
suis à paris
ma grand mère ma mère est arrivée là
débutants et à la maison on écoutait
plus tôt yves montand way edith piaf que
c'est ça la vraie vie je sais non pas
saloperies thierry ne soit pas dur
non que c'est bien mais quand on sent
par exemple par rapport à smaïn qui lui
assume ça complètement un message si
l'on vous vous rencontrez par exemple et
on est très copain je dois ça et puis je
suis plus français que toi par exemple
j'ai le quart d'identity gilles gardien
ty ifri si j'ai fait les batailles du
monde ticket psy non non pas du tout je
dire je trouve que c'est ce qui fait
c'est bien et tout c'est son truc il le
fait il le fait très bien
moi je serais incapable de le faire j'ai
dit on va aussi tous les ingénieurs si
tous les beurs situer nombreux on devait
faire les beurs giresse vois pas
l'intérêt y'en a un ghana elmer que des
éleveurs est très bon et là tu vois il
le fait très bien moi j'ai fait autre
chose et ça se complète puis ça alors en
suivant
en france elle tient bon j'arrive à tu
peux mettre un peu plus fort parce que
là on avait la main sur blanc car c'est
là-bas que s'inspirer je suis du coin
jamais été chanté par les porteurs
travaux sur wii ah non je peux je pense
que ces deux mecs c'est mendez
ouais bravo à temps les gars stade roi
deux coups bas doit beaucoup à toi
temptation ce nom alors ses papiers sont
à l'honneur
ouais c'est terrible oui chaptes leur
rendre ce qu'ils faisaient ça c'est pas
grave on ne demande pas qu'est ce qu'ils
chantent enfin demain poitrinal enlevant
la planète le morceau aux biches et
isaac hayes à gaza
farid tué bêta tu vois ce malheureux
ouais
du côté des jeux
il a commencé
les messieurs n'ont pas de pièces je
suis d'accord c'est le facteur c'est la
vie
tél
farid je souffre pour toi vraiment lâché
fait l'ag valeur pour toi reid
voilà j'ai un trou dans chaque bus way
j'ai eu peur toute menue il ya bourvil
dans le bourg est là c'est bien là le
dis bravo à l'atp toutefois pas à toi et
je vais et jacqueline maillan et
jacqueline mon toit fermeture j'aurais
trouvé ville et jacqueline maillan je
t'aime moi non plus c'est pas près de s
ouais c'est extraordinaire je voudrais
pas eu des pointures en france
je m'excuse discours les algues vertes
fc marc marquez ouverture on va
applaudir gainsbourg mes enfants et mon
établissement
élus et à gagner leur aide à gagner
[Applaudissements]
graziella de michel potelet morte une
bombe de nantes
elle chante à l'aide de jersey extrait
de son premier album le clown alicante
[Musique]
oui cet homme qui me l'a dit
m
[Musique]
d'ici le jour et
les
enfin compris
lee
pour
oh
[Musique]
bleu clair
et toi sont prêts pour la tempête
je ne sais pas
donne pas mal
à pau les onze ans
[Musique]
ou emilie
mais tu sais bien
moi aussi j'ai mes soucis loin
[Musique]
tu t'en sortir
six ans
je
moi je crois
toi tu là
emilie
ga
ne
des amis
[Musique]
hu
rien
mais vous ça se voit ça
bah
je sais
mais
oh
[Musique]
ans
tous
[Musique]
tu sais
c'est
paris
[Musique]
c'était graziella de michel et voilà
végal à l'étoile filante de lunettes
très nette
alan vega do things that was the last
ranker nov non
[Musique]
non
ouais ou du mythe martin rives
non il dit
swiss a expliqué martin using polisario
music baby lou reed in france
you know bâillon libération libération
faisait 10 heures et 10 heures
là je vais vraiment pas terribles all
too big to feel à the good genuine
artistes peintures bio blythe travaux
ils ne valent fameux one a110 sont avant
tout bien étrange non le castor pierre
enfin malgré tout paris autour du bar
des cakes de marichez laico privilège
storti nouvelle le chouchou françoise
lacroix ariane lamballe lacroix marie
jean nouvelle game marie lacroix marie
lacroix dombasle thomas marie lacroix
béatrice manon et paquita
ça c'est françoise la croix c'est ça
mary bale à ce concert frenchkiss la
venue de la semaine ici pas connu là bas
2 millions d'albums vendus s'étonne
locke fait dans le rap attaque banzaï
lundi 24 avril les héritiers énerver les
endimanchés au théâtre du fon 26 rue de
meaux jeudi 27 avril 26 et vise à la
cigale le théâtre de l'albatros présente
un pablo picasso monologue mis en scène
par rené bocquier construit sur des
poèmes écrits entre 1905 et 1975 par ses
amis max jacob jean cocteau pour l'élu à
arzacq prévert louis aragon mise en
musique par simon chémery à la guitare
interprété par elisabeth placèrent c'est
pas un saint castin
[Musique]
comment
m
[Musique]
c'est un puzzle rue princesse annexe ii
questel que les parasites transit aps le
cabaret y'a qu'ça d'vrai surtout quand
ils reprennent la main la moto qui
attend verlan au micro ct noirs beurs
l'un des compères du case faut avoir lu
ça super exclu la semaine prochaine le
nouveau clip you re dans l'une est
extrait de leur dernier prendre trois
designs et grace a signalé lundi 24
avril sur antenne 2 un excellent
documentaire de 52 minutes sur le rail
rachid bouchareb la semaine prochaine
super exclu nuque bashung live au palace
on
pierrette brès sophie duez nicoletta
pierre mondy mais est il des mais jean
pierre rat le fond où ça au cirque
d'hiver pourquoi pour voir nos magasins
au mac
la seule ça tient chaud en avril pas
d'un fil basile est ce que vous savez
que ces deux là ont refusé deux concerts
au royal albert hall pourquoi parce que
les petits enfants n'avaient pas le
droit de monter sur scène au mc enroe
mac c'est le grand retour de la famille
la lecture de la semaine jalons la
lettre confidentielle d'asile de
l'époque françois léotard prépare un
ouvrage de philosophie le titre et la
préface sont prêts mais le sujet n'est
pas encore déterminée le chef terroriste
abou nidal et toujours réfugié dans la
supérette de garges-lès-gonesse il
demande maintenant un ouvre-boîte est un
jeu de 1000 bornes pour relâcher les
cinq crédits qu'il détient toujours en
otage
basile de koch chalon y'a qu'ça d'vrai
bout mcenroe mcteer doivent circuler
vers des zaz et albert
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais sinon une aide celui qu ariane
achète alan vega loser magnifique du
rock minimaliste mais gilles fait le
maximum avec son pote martin ritt de
suicide
surrender seller 45 extraits de leurs 33
way of life
produit par ric ocasek des cars pas guy
bande de nazes
m
nommé
[Musique]
holmes
[Applaudissements]
à jeumont
aso
[Musique]
oui j'ai de fonds
montceau
[Musique]
tu as
à seraing
[Musique]
aso
ans
c'était swissaid martinoli valan dégâts
voici la fin nous avons les moyens de
vous retrouver la semaine prochaine
même motif même punition c'était
lunettes avec oliver reed
graziella de michel sûr
jean-michel arrive
[Musique]
farid chopel jean louis murat
dominique fernandez et alan vega salle
au dos bandidos naissance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah oui
roy
[Musique]
et
oui oui
m
bah
[Musique]
pour les hommes
wade
[Musique]
m
roy
[Musique]
m
oui oui
bah
mais
[Musique]
m
wade
[Musique]
très grave
mais
wwa est
[Musique]
et
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu